これじゃあ肇社長とスーパー
何履いて外スーパーあるが今日ですねこちらプールにくれるよ
ああああああ
ああああ私チームを鼓舞コーラとして東京2020オリンピックを盛り上げるために
活動しております
そして今回こちらプールに入っているということで今回のゲストはすごいですよ
rar
よ創造しているよそうだわー
そう renarena
tee
よろしくお願いますお願いします
へへー緊張してるんですけどテレビラファんですよ
的で北島さんはですねコカコーラチークオリンピック担当オフィサーとして活動して
おられます
理論をにて行きメダルを掲げているということで14年前
10年前ですかお会い出来ると思っていてすごい高齢です
霊性が今日はそんな夢のような人たちまさに
辛党と思います
ブーブーしかーし
ブーブー1機しかだぞ
いや堀ガーン
ドクターの道だ手を常普請今まで見たことないんで
今まで隠されていた部の子様記録と太海よっています
rar
wh
ああああああ
me
強報告に興味が一味違うよーございます
the まずは何もなしできますいきますはいといえばひろふみなんでここで平泳ぎで
お願いしまーす
てるわけないんですけどもう it をするということで説明をねーぞ
まずは様子見です相手の出方をうかがいます
ああああああ
安い wh
池がもうなんですよ1回でロ
rar
当たり前でしょうかあってる国家だった国が本腰は
に帰ってくるちょっと特殊なほどしていると思うんでスタッフがロケ r ガールです
よ
25じゃそうはなりません
はいすげーにかいいね目なんですけど枚こちらを使わせてください
収納型です
変わるかさっき言われるんですけどいや実ダジャレさである行き過ぎなんですよ
なんでこれだから a に次せずにずっといけるとそうでそうでずっと書いていけると
か
ちょっと勝機が見えるんじゃないかと思いません早期は見えると思うな
ni
tee
身近されるだろうか水 waianae ああああ
mar
re you doing
ブーブー言っは
ぞ最強なのって
dj mar
rar
受け負けてるんだよなぁベンツ r 4しています
ちょっとドキッとしたそれだけ
第3作がエチレンを書けということなんですけども次が方べ波タイムです
を楽しむいいハイ2最終戦なんですけどねはい
希望完封にはこれしかないぞというものを持ってきました
終わってますかいや0これはどうでしょうこちら
ブーブー言っに3つのさ
だと思うので是非とも今度ただせていただきます
いい少々値配分は4種類あります
yeah
me
よろしけれ
dare
ああああああ
ちょっとセンターのみじゃねぇ
それでも負けてスプーンたは今
狙う true
いやー石火はちょっと僕が寄ってきたそれでも買っちゃえばーい
ゲージにをもって終了しました
noa
re j オマール ejn オーデータ
maa
ほどテレビで3つですごいだと思ってるんですけど生で見ると本当にすごかったです
やっぱり生で見る感動ってやつとス絶対あると思ってそうねやっぱ臨場感であったり
そこの場所の空間であったり
オリンピックはぜひねんこれ
ナマで入っちゃった
そう専門生で見たいんですけれども生でオリンピック見る時って
スキットが眠れないんですよそこでなんとですねはい
銀子で東京2020オリンピックの観戦チケットが当たるキャンペーンを実施中ですで
これでとにかく簡単に下がるキャンペーンなんですけども
高校のアプリを開いてその場でチケットが当たりますそれ
風でも何度でも応募可能でございますつけたと語った
ビリー東山がスポーツ好きなんで
父ちゃんをそれ
てみたいこともう4位はもちろんてきたし可動棚夜のリンクからチェックしてみて
ください
そしてチームコカコーラのツイッターインスタグラムのフォローは youtube
チャンネルの登録もよろしくお願いしますそれじゃあねもうすぐも
交えてしまって美味しかったますっ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
wh
ああああああ
ええええええ
ねぇ超気持ちえぐっちゃん出ましたアーメイいけないですよねー
hey